thank you thank you
man oh man
what a night what a moment
gracias
wow uh
well stand before you with immense Pride
and gratitude
as I humbly accept this huge honor of
being inducted into the Nays made
Basketball Hall of Fame
I want to express my deepest
appreciation to the selection committee
or bestowing this amazing recognition
upon me
this moment is a testament
to a support guidance and inspiration I
have received from so many through all
my basketball Journey
I've always remember the moment that
Jericho Angela
called me in to tell me the magic words
you're in
a pretty powerful moment
I gotta tell you
I know my fellow inductees
will remember it too
congratulations to all of you it's truly
an honor to be in the same class
thank you
baby I told me when I was young a little
kid growing up in a little city samboy
but someday I would not only meet Tony
kukoc but that he'd be presenting me
into the Hall of Fame I wouldn't believe
you
and yet here we are
Tony was a great player heck of a player
man I mean he inspired so many European
players growing up I looked up to you
you inspired me to follow your steps
I thought it was going to be a small
forward uh you know but I kept on
growing and growing you know until I was
20. so I ended up playing closer to the
basket having to face Timmy and
kg and Dirk
uh but who knows maybe in today's game I
would have been a small forward who
knows shooting threes all kinds of stuff
anyway it turned out pretty good for me
so uh thank you so much for this
incredible incredible honor
so I also wanted to thank my friend and
role model Kareem Abdul-Jabbar I think
maybe many of you knew know that he was
going to be here being also one of my
presenters unfortunately he couldn't
make it he felt yesterday under the
weather
I just want to say uh you know wish you
well hope you're well Kareem and thank
you for accepting the honor of being my
presenter
[Applause]
man so so many people have contributed
contribute me to me for being here uh
but no one like my family I uh my dear
parents
um who introduced me to the game of
basketball they both played at an
amateur level but they played
um thank you so much for all your
teachings
for your support for your love never
missing the game never
Miss into practice taking me to
practices after you work
you've inspired me your commitment your
efforts your sacrifices have fueled me
and motivated me thank you Mom and Dad I
love you so very much so very much
for my brothers my brothers Mark and
Adria
been growing up with Margo special you
guys have had the chance to watch his
MBA career that he was a special special
kid
you know some shooting Hoops that are
grandparents backyard and competing
already he always tried to beat me
um you know I always try to make sure
that he knew that I was a big brother he
shouldn't beat me but he did it start
you know at some point he you know he
grew up
um he played for our country
we played many championships won medals
um man
we got traded for each other
crazy I think we are the only brothers
who ever got traded for each other
and and we experienced one of the most
special things I think in our career
which was a jumbo at the All-Star Game
in 2015 at the Madison Square Garden you
know it was pretty special to share that
truly unbelievable thank you Mark
[Applause]
and my brother Adria wasn't particularly
interested in basketball early on he we
used to bring books when I used to play
in Memphis just reading his book his
comic books
but um you know he's the only one in our
family that got a master's degree in
business so uh I'm very proud to have
you both as brothers thank you love you
and I wanted to I wanted to take a
moment to recognize all the players some
of you are here coaches that have come
before me
that paved the way the build this
amazing League
thank you all for your contributions I
truly truly appreciate them thank you
[Applause]
and being being from where I'm from you
know from from Europe Spain I wanted to
give a special mention to those first
Europeans
that came here across the ocean that
took a chance
and opened doors for players like myself
Fernando Martin the first Spanish player
to ever play in the NBA Johnson
petrovich sarunas Marshall and his
deathless
Dino Raja Rick Smith's amazing players
thank you
[Applause]
seven years old
he's having fun with friends at school
with my classmates
but then 1992 happened you know the
Olympics in Barcelona
I was 12. it changed my life
the dream team showed us how basketball
could be played
it made me dream of playing at that
level
playing with the best of the best
and that launched really an incredible
growth in the sport internationally in
the 2023 class
is a true Testament of it so thank you
to the Dream Team 1982 so those teams
also European teams that competed
against them you know didn't do so well
but
but you know it is what it is they were
pretty good
then when I was 13 years old my coach at
uh the next thing that I played my first
club team that I played at CV Cornelia
gave me a chance to play point guard
for a game teaching me how hard that
position was it was extremely humbling
obviously I struggled tremendously
guiding a guy that was five two and
really quick having to bring them all up
and down the court
but it um but what I took from that
experience is that those ages I think
the importance is to to teaching and
growing you know not so much focusing on
winning and losing so um that's that's
an important message I think to keep and
especially you know at all levels in the
world as we're trying to teach our kids
to play basketball girls and boys
a couple years later a guy that I was
guarding he's a tough turnaround jumper
I'm like ouch what what do what do I do
how can I defend that they said nothing
he'll be you know he used to play he was
a guy from FC Barcelona by the time I
wasn't there yet he said don't worry
he'll make it to the pros and you won't
so okay
okay I guess
um I mean we all faced moments and
comments like that throughout our lives
and careers
but I've always embraced him you know
allow them to motivate me and uh and
help me grow
and then the next level I went to FC
Barcelona where I played with many great
coaches and players
um some of them have become great
friends today and I know a special
mention to my good friend and Juan
Carlos Navarro who was a special player
special talent
not just with with FC Barcelona with
this with Spain we're great great
friends and great players so I wanted to
acknowledge him because he really
inspired me to
to be a better player at that time
then after the NBA
you know got drafted 2001. thank you for
the Grizzlies for giving me the
opportunity to play in the NBA for
fulfilling my dream
when I first arrived in Memphis I was
like wow a pyramid
I guess all NBA teams play in pyramids
here
it's kind of different but you know
pretty cool I guess uh man I still
remember our first press conference with
Shane and will Solomon that also got
drafted with us my English was very
limited
I wasn't very comfortable speaking what
I knew which was very little
but I quickly recognized that my day my
teammate here was very tickled and very
smart
so I just had to follow what he said
right so when the media asked us how we
felt about the NBA being in Memphis
first time the team just moved from
Vancouver
and Shane went first obviously I was
smart enough to allow him to go first
and they wanted to I mean he was a fan
favorite uh you know all NBA great guy
um so I just repeated the last word that
I understood you know
that I was able to identify that it was
electrifying
sounded good right
under good
so thank you Shane for being here
tonight I love you
[Applause]
I'm proud of my years in Memphis the
work that we did we set the foundation
for with the Grizzlies have become
some of those people that were there at
that time Billy Knight Michael Heisley
Sidney Lowe Mike Miller Lorenzen Wright
Jason Williams throw miles Swift
Hubie Brown Jerry West and Mike Fratello
I mean amongst many others obviously
thank you all for everything that you
did at that time during my career
and for the City of Memphis
February 1st 2008 you know Chris Wallace
calls me to his office and gives me the
news that I was traded to the Los
Angeles Lakers
[Applause]
that obviously changed changed my life
in my career I know some people in the
league were upset about the trade
but it happened right
and that's um
and that's where I got to know the
person who elevated my game
like no other
who taught me what it took to win at the
highest level
who showed me how hard you had to work
and the mentality you needed to have in
order to be the best
the commitment you had to make what it
meant and what it took to be a leader
Kobe
[Applause]
that night that night I joined the team
in DC and I got to the hotel after
midnight you know he was texting me
saying Hey I want to come buy your room
and I want to welcome you I want to say
hello when I'm I want to welcome you to
the team I said you know what I mean
it's going to be late it's going to be
like past 1 a.m you sure you don't want
to wait for tomorrow you said no no I'm
it's not going to be so late I'm coming
I'm coming over set up okay sounds good
the team had a game next day at noon so
all right
so he just wanted to make sure that
right away firsthand I got the message
say welcome to the team
I'm happy you're here now let's go win a
championship together
so I said all right I'm in man I'm in
have a good night that was it that was
it
ish that was it no no crap straight
straight to the chase
I wouldn't be here without you brother
I wish more than anything that you and
Gigi are here today with us
I miss you and love you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you Vanessa for being
here tonight
um proud to be your brother
thank you
and an uncle and an uncle to your
wonderful girls I love you guys so very
much
we needed it all together 2009 2010 it
was super special I mean that's what you
work for right we've been talking about
this the last few days with dirt with D
Wade with Tony so I want to thank the
Lakers organization the bus family Rob
thank you for being here with your
family tonight
Linda Rambis Mitch cup check the amazing
coaching staff that we had my teammates
Derek Fisher Amar Odom Andrew Bynum
Luke who's here tonight thank you for
being here Sasha Jordan Trevor Meadow
I'm so grateful to all of you I hope
that that you take
this honor that I'm receiving today as
part of your own without you I couldn't
have done it
a special thank you to Phil Jackson
what a truly incredible man
besides besides showing us how to play a
triangle I think the most important
things were
um what he taught us about mindfulness
about meditation
about blocking the noise
encouraged us to read you know cultivate
our minds
thank you Phil for that
then I had the chance the chance to go
to Chicago
the team that we grew up pretty much all
idolizing and following the Bulls played
two years for the Bulls got to know an
amazing city thank you Jerry and Michael
reislo for being here tonight very
special two years
from there I signed with this verse the
San Antonio Spurs
what an amazing what an amazing
franchise
pop Becky
Tony Manu I mean one of the things that
Bob told me during free agency and and I
talked to Timmy I talked to mano they're
they're you know they're strong right
their pitch is really strong so think
about the guys that you're going to
spend time with think about the guys
that you're going to be in the bus with
and the playing with and in Israel right
we spent a lot of time with teammates in
our teams so I I just love the
opportunity to play with you guys it was
it was truly an amazing experience and
I've always forever be thankful thank
you RC also for the opportunity my wife
and I will always cherish those three
years in San Antonio we had so many
great memories
um and we'll forever
love them
I learned I learned I learned so many
things about pop
obviously the basketball stuff you know
the good to great
play harder and smarter than your
opponent for 48 minutes all that good
stuff
it's very important
but I'll never forget one of the things
that he said that I will take with me
and I've taken with me and I've applied
it was Valentine's Day when he asked
did you guys get your significant others
flowers
and some of us proudly said yes yes
absolutely yes for sure of course
and he followed up with well why does he
have to be Valentine's Day for you guys
to give flowers to your loved ones
so I thought that was a very important
message thank you Bob
and lastly the last thing that'll be
walking bugs where I ended my my career
it seemed like the miles that I put on
my body finally caught up with me so you
know it is what it is
um of course you cannot understand my
career and me as a player without my
national team La Familia so many battles
with with friends
um we made each other better you guys
pushed us
to to earn every one of those all those
games
um against the way USA team there are so
many battles in Germany
representing
for me representing my country was a big
big deal such a privilege
so um
but today we're going into the Hall of
Fame together how crazy is that how
beautiful is that
[Applause]
all right I wanna I wanna thank my
agents uh Aaron and Stephen uh for
guiding me throughout my MBA career
thank you for being here tonight both of
you by both are amazing to all the
physios the strength coaches the staff
team doctors the security
you know everyone in the organization
that allows us to do our job we couldn't
do it without you and we appreciate your
job and dedication so very much all the
media thank you so much for everything
that you do for giving us the platform
to reach hundreds of millions out there
and I wanted to take a second to
especially acknowledge my my trainer
Joaquin who was uh was being with me for
20 20 years or throughout my career and
committed to me
to enhance me as a player to be a good
friend
and to prolong my career as long as I
did thank you
so my wife to my lovely my lovely lovely
lovely wife I'm I'm the luckiest man
um thank you love
thank you for being my best friend
thank you for being patient with me for
dealing with my ups and downs for
complimenting me
you're the best I'm so lucky to be your
husband I'm so lucky to be a father to
our Ellie and Max you're the best and
you know transitioning from the NBA to
the next chapter is not easy you know I
don't you know I don't care we talked
about it with Shane years ago you go
through a dip right it's you've got to
figure things out it's a big shock
especially emotionally no matter I mean
I was able to you know prepare for it
build things along the way
but still you struggle and having the
support of my wife throughout that time
throughout this time
has made it possible for me so thank you
love
[Applause]
and to wrap to wrap up
uh as the old phrase has it to whom much
is giving much is required
I truly believe it
those values the pursuit of Excellence
the drive to succeed the love of family
the recognition to give back the power
of empathy the ones instill both my
blind parents both working in health
care home by Kobe always wanted to be
extraordinary and Epic
and encouraged and supported by my
beautiful wife and family
they're the reason I'm committed to
working to make a bigger difference in
our world and I want to encourage you
all to continue to find ways to join
efforts to team up so our impact can be
much larger we have a unique opportunity
to do so
thank you all very much
[Applause]
foreign